[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jour j demain c'est fini les mariages
là on passe au stade supérieur nafi à
l'étape pas demain je ne peux pas ta
compagne et demain j'ai moi j'y vais
passer entre un papa derniers jours
j'aimerais bien que tu accompagnes
d'alata soeur de masse au rendez vous
tous merci match est évidemment non il
invite dans la même liste s'est pas
moins non qu'on s'est pas vu quand on
est jeune une heure toutes les deux on
n'a rien à se dire et là tu nous manques
de faire quatre heures de route ensemble
ces deux derniers tours des auditions
pour les choristes francophone de céline
on me dis pas que tu dit céline fort ces
lignes on ne veut pas dire pascal elle
s'appelle céline
moi j'ai ma fille
ça fait plaisir ouais
pierre mayeur
c'était impulsion août est fatigué on a
quatre heures de route on va pas se
parler pendant quatre heures 6
c'est bizarre de vouloir être choriste
vouloir être derrière quelqu'un qui fait
le même métier qu à cacher dans le noir
je trouve ça hyper étrangers trop
les communes à dire je te dérange je
pose des questions tu me réponds que par
oui ou par non
c'est un calcaire faire un attrait
platoir ça ça pour être les paroles
d'une chanson vous vivez dans quel monde
tu vas y toi encore papa quoi papa c'est
quoi le problème c'est que je parle
comme vous moi je veux pas mentir je
pense à vouloir vous protéger des
malades les malades papa et nous on est
là
je voulais pas que tu saches
je fais quoi avec ça je fais quoi
c'est fini ça
il
[Musique]